hello everyone this is samir from
audioscience review i have another
product review for you it's the cord
hugo
tt2
um as you probably have seen i've tested
uh just about all their other products
dax and
people kept talking about this tt2 being
special different so it was fortuitous
that a member had one to send me for
testing
it's quite expensive
twenty five 6725 for a dac and a
headphone amplifier so expectation is
quite high as far as what performance it
should produce
um
chord designs are core key to say the
least usually with some kind of light
show and these globes and everything i
found this version of it to be worse
through the bunch
it's got a green
dot matrix led
display in here that's hard to read
slanted and it's kind of dim and it auto
shuts off all the time
these
labels here you can see them well in my
picture but if you're looking from above
they're almost impossible to see and
read you get used to them but you know
it's just these are little things you
want to get right uh
on this thing
fortunately it comes with a
sort of a cheap looking
you know remote but it works a lot
better than trying to navigate that
unfortunately not everything's on the
remote so a simple thing like a menu
button to push to go in there and change
the gain is not in here so you have to
go back and use the box again
so overall i'm not a fan of it but you
don't come to my reviews to hear about
my opinion of the hardware itself
i've got the specs in here you're
welcome to go read it
most of my testing is focused on xlr
output and headphone output but i also
tested rca briefly and i'll show you
that so starting with our xlr and
setting the gain to low which gives you
the best performance and adjusting level
as close as i could to 4 volts it's kind
of hard it goes from 4.3 and then jumps
down to 3 point something so i gave it
the benefit of that and selected 4.3
volts we get a sum of distortion and
noise as stayed in sign out of 115 db
115 db is a very good number
uh you know lands well inside of our
excellent bucket
but
for this class of product i expected to
be all the way towards the end there
if i zoom in the products around it you
actually see products like this smsl
balance stack is only 170 dollars
and
so
it's not a good place to be if you want
to sell on performance and the company
is very keen on doing that
the xlr output on this thing puts out
tons of voltage and depending on whether
you use low gain or high gain it can go
all the way up to
almost 16 volts of output in high gain
with very good performance similar
performance at 115 db so if you have a
low gain power amplifier
then this would be a good pairing is
essentially pro level
output levels on this uh as i mentioned
i also measured rca and the performance
is the same there's some people saying
like internally single ended it's not a
balanced stack so single ended must be
better but again i'm set the voltage to
2 volt as nominal for that and cyanide
did not change
the issue with the stack if we can call
it an issue is that its noise
performance not that great yes it gives
you 19 bits of dynamic range in here
but state of the art dax go up to 20-22
bits so it's way way behind as far as
how good dax gotten and how silent
they've gotten
and
they only provide one spec of 127 db
which is extremely good if they could
get that but it uses a weighting which
is a way to chop off a lot of low
frequency noise but even after i did
that i only got up to 120 not 127.
and
they need to specify voltage or test
conditions or how they got to 127 and
unfortunately they do not so you know
we're stuck with what's there so we're
done we don't get the spec and we don't
get a competitive number
uh intermodulation uh noise and
distortion reflects the
non-competitive noise level this uh
dashed line in blue is the reference i
have is a 250 deck and headphone amp and
look at this guy it's
the tt2 struggles to match it until it
almost gets to the end then it has less
distortion but as far as noise which is
one of the simplest things to hear uh it
doesn't do
any better from this you compare this
two or three year old
very very budget deck and i think noise
is also responsible for this linearity
not being ruler flat any even budget dax
today at 150
will nail this test with you know flat
response to 20 bits minus 120 db
and this one can't do it you can see
that it's getting wiggliness
you know all the way throughout on this
so
uh you know sort of audibility and
everything is great but it's just
competitively it's not distortion is
well very much under control and it's
frequency independent as far as the
noise floor at the bottom so this is 21
bits i think state of the art is 22 bits
or a little bit more but you know i'm
not going to fault this that much as
much as the noise
performance is excellent whether i use
toslink or usb but the noise floor is
high this this needs to be at the bottom
of this graph almost falling off the
bottom
and if it did that maybe we would see
more of the spikes but as it is is it's
excellent performance so not a big
complaint
claim to fame of cortex is that they
they use very high tap
fur filters and those high tap filters
allow them to have a very sharp
transition between what should be there
what should not be there this vertical
line in red is what the ideal deck would
be and many decks we see a slow slope
over here that goes two or three kilos
before it goes down this one does it
extremely fast uh which is a good thing
and also the attenuation level how much
it cuts off the stuff this outer band is
is very very good so as far as what its
claim to fame is objectively it's
accomplishing that
it has four different uh filters though
and you see them all landing on top of
each other that's because this this
chart doesn't have very high vertical
resolution so
if we zoom way in where we're only plus
or minus 2 db and i run different tests
we can see that there are four
filters but two of them
there's only two different ones when it
comes to audible impact two of them land
on top of each other with this roll off
that goes as low as three kilohertz
but doesn't do a significant amount
until you go after
10 kilos or so and then two that have
barely any roll-off at all i uh
the manual is obscure talks about
filtering
ultrasonics i went ahead and extended
the response
to 96 kilohertz and even then i barely
see a difference as far as i'm concerns
really has two filters
one of them is flat the other one is not
i suggest using the flat one they call
this one warmer i don't know how much
warmth you get out of chopping off a
little bit of 10 to 20 kilohertz but
anyway it's there you can play with it
that good filter always results in a
good showing in this test and we can see
that the wideband noise and distortion
is flat which is excellent and it's
quite low it's not a state-of-the-art
because the state of the art would be
down here but
really hard to fault it on this one so
this is a very good showing
now in the last review of the court dave
that i did a lot of people came back
repeating company's argument about time
domain performance
the company doesn't provide any
measurements uh to prove anything that
they're saying as far as time
measurements is uh you know measurable
little audible
and people keep asking and saying well
you didn't run an impulse response and
run impulse response so i spent some
time developing an impulse response
and and made a comparison with a very
traditional dac which is this topping
d70s that's sitting on my bench and
generate an impulse response the one in
blue which happens with no delay is
essentially no delay is the topping
we can see that the uh
core deck has a substantial 35
millisecond delay
because that fur filter needs many audio
samples before and after
where the signal comes out so it has to
buffer that much before it starts
playing
and at high level there's no difference
between these two as you can see they
both have a rise and a
drop on the other side and
you know they look the same but to be
fair we need to zoom way in and see the
detail in there so that's what i've done
first i've magnified the heck out of the
vertical scale so this is much much
zoomed in so we're really looking at the
tails of these things which is where the
company talks about and the number of
taps and everything shows up and then
the other thing i did was that i grabbed
this one and i grabbed this and i lined
them up inside my photoshop
program so both
the blue and the red so the topping and
the cord are both sitting over here as
far as their main impulse and they're
both trailing like this and you can see
that the blue and red are basically the
same
these are the actual oscillations and
then they both blend into the noise
around the same amount of time so i see
no difference in pre-echo as this is
called it's not the correct term but
pre-ringing
that's in there it's there's no
difference but what is the difference
kind of interesting is that
when we go a little bit past the noise
level all of a sudden the chord gets a
discontinuity in here where the response
goes to plus or minus infinity
relatively speaking infinity whereas the
topping is just flat and just gone to
noise floor and it just settles there
and if i just show you that chord
response by itself so you can easily see
it this is the first one but if i zoom
out you can see that it keeps repeating
and
so that's not a good thing i don't know
why you would want this now the
amplitude of this is so small does to
not make an audible impact uh because
again it's sort of one of these little
ticks over here that you can barely see
but you know objectively the company
talks about zooming in minus 300 db and
looking inside and there are little bits
that are better and nicer well i don't
see that and i see basically what looks
like a computational flaw windowing
flaws some kind of flying usually you
don't get this in infer filters so i
don't know why it's there and then it's
repeating you can also see it drift in
here where the levels are shifting down
to two
uh microvolts uh so
that's not good either if you look over
here the topping stays you know right at
zero over here now i'm not going to say
any of this is audible at all you can't
interpret an impulse response with a
human eye and
and talk about it
all this talk about you know smearing
all that stuff is all nonsense uh that's
not how the brain works at that this
kind of resolution uh but if it is we
certainly don't have objective proof in
favor of the court we actually have
this measurement against it this is why
it's good to ask the company for
measurement when they say oh our impulse
response is great and you know the
filter is perfect and everything is like
okay don't just say those things
demonstrate it show it make a simple
comparison and then we can see i don't
know why the company doesn't show it
whether they don't have the data or or
if they have it doesn't look good i
don't know but
here it is you know you have the timing
information
let's switch to the headphone amplifier
uh the noise performance is really poor
in there i'm making measurements at 50
millivolts
which is what you need for a very
sensitive iem
and or
headphone and
we only get about 78 db average between
the two 78 db for plotted against you
know 100 some other
headphone items that i've tested
lands well below average this is where
it's sitting and the state of the art is
out here around 95 db or so so
it is way way down there so i'd say i'm
sensitive i am just going to hiss and
and uh buzz or whatever noise background
noise that it has so it's not suitable
for that
uh and it should be at this price
um
there's plenty of power available this
is using the front quarter inch uh plug
if you use a high gain you get about 230
milliwatts
and which is a lot i like to see at
least 100 milliwatts
excuse me
and
selecting low gain also cause clipping
still which is strange to me the whole
point of low gain is that you're not
driving the amplifier
for it to clip so
this is somehow still clipping which is
strange
but anyway performance noise floor you
can see still higher than the reference
that i have is cheaper tapping deck
that's now obsolete does better as far
as noise
but but the tt2 has more power than it
um switching to the other that was 300
ohm load this is 32 ohm load and
we see similar kind of picture where
there's more power available about
almost 2 watts
but the noise is still not competitive
on this thing
and
if i
change the load impedance all the way
down to 12 ohms we see that
using quarter inch output in the front
basically is able to maintain the same
voltage and keep increasing power every
time you go to lower impedance
there's enough current in there to keep
doubling and this is pretty unusual and
very good
from point of view of driving low
impedance headphones
uh on this
there is a funky feature in this thing
that's only available in this i've never
seen it elsewhere now you can use xlr
output in the back as also a headphone
output or even a speaker up with the
company says you of course have to make
your own custom cable that goes from
there to your headphones only three pin
and it's two up two connectors that have
to drive one one headphone so you have
to build that yourself or buy one i
don't know if there's a commercial one
but not a big deal you can do that so i
went ahead and measured it i didn't have
the right adapter and i could only
measure the 300 ohm and indeed the power
goes through the roof quadruples almost
uh using the differential outputs in the
back so we now get almost one watt at
300 ohms that's a ton a ton of power so
even a 600 ohm impedance headphone or
even higher even if it's insensitive is
no match for this thing if you use the
rear connectors at the same time be
careful it can blow up those headphones
and it can also blow up your ears as
much as i'm a fan of playing loud and
everything you get to pretty dangerous
levels when you have so much voltage and
current coming out of the thing
basically it's a mini power amplifier
sitting inside the thing
i did some listening tests the company
loves the dan clark stealth headphone
which i also have there's a 4 000
headphone quite expensive but it's got
one of the lowest distortions i've ever
measured and it's very neutral so you
don't need any dsp to correct it and i
listen to a range of reference tracks
that i listen to all the time i've
listened to these strikes probably a
thousand times
and
i could detect no difference in
with this stack versus
hundreds of other decks that i've
listened to
same resolution same dynamic same
everything and it sounds excellent these
are great tracks that i use for testing
and all of them sounded perfect but no
more perfect than any other act that
i've tested you know it's just no magic
in there and any of this filtering and
so forth
that the company claims um with dan
clark stealth headphone this is a tough
headphone to drive and uh i could get it
quite loud but if i went a little bit
further past that it would get distorted
which almost every app does so
um but this was using the quarter inch
in front if i'd use the rear one it
probably could drive it without getting
distorted but you know plenty powerful
for that headphone you know for everyday
use
uh with the hd650 sennheiser
high impedance headphone it's more
sensitive and there's just a tremendous
amount of dynamics and power available
so just like any other high performance
headphone amplifier
it produced great sound
so
the
upshot of this thing is that you have
excellent performance over here if this
if i had never tested any other attack
and hephenam this was the first one that
i was testing i would say wow this is
this is great
but the world has moved on since this
company court put out this stack there's
been a race and who can get the lowest
noise maximum power least amount of
distortion in the market and at the
incredibly budget prices uh you know six
or seven hundred dollars expensive in
that domain let alone six thousand
dollars so um the world has moved on and
now they have left this product behind
you can get
all of this performance except for the
filter
uh in
10 of the price of this and frankly they
look better in my opinion they're easier
to use than this hodgepodge of design
features and buttons and globes and
lights and
and just quirkiness and by the way this
doesn't look expensive to me either i
mean it's if you had a family member
come look at and say what'd you buy for
six thousand dollars you'd be like
you bought this
it just
doesn't look fancy and then by the way i
will pay thousands of dollars for
something that looks really fancy and
performs i have no problem buying five
or ten thousand dollar deck if it came
in gorgeous cabinet and you know proper
piece of hifi
but anyway uh beyond that you're
basically paying six thousand dollars
for that filter so you got to decide
whether you know it's worth it to just
have that filter it has no audible
impact that i can detect on that
so i can't recommend this thing for you
to buy but if you own it
nothing about this review says it's a
terrible device it's an extremely high
performance device
it's noise and distortion if you're
using it with less sensitive devices is
transparent it's state-of-the-art uh
this isn't state-of-the-art it's
transparent to your hearing so it's
gonna play the source material as good
as your sources and your limiting factor
would be your headphones that you're
hooking up to it
but if you don't own one
rushing out to buy this thing it just
makes no sense to me
for many many reasons that i've talked
about you're just better off buying a
desktop dex you can get this combo of
features and most of that performance
for a couple hundred dollars two or
three hundred dollars and then you can
go state-of-the-art six seven hundred
dollars and and you're done
and
uh you know should it break or something
you don't have to deal with servicing
something like this and uh by the way
this thing runs warm and
on this thing so i don't know what the
reliability is going to be longer term
on this okay
so with this we're done testing chord
uk
products
for a while at least
hope you got something out of it see you
in a future video bye